the word father lucius refers to the
class system which existed during the
old Imperium in the Dune universe the
fat free lucious system was designed to
maintain control of certain groups
within the Imperium and also to offer
some sort of order to the manner in
which humans related to one another
the motto of the Father lucious was a
place for every man and every man in his
place great and minor houses played a
key role in the father lucious Great
Houses could be granted Sereda
or planetary fiefdom which granted them
rule over a planet and its subjects
their duty would be to uphold imperial
law as well as maintain the social order
required for the father Lucius to
function after collecting taxes and
economic profits from the planet's
populace the governor of the planet
usually referred to as sorry dar was
required to pay tithes to the imperial
house a planetary fief could be held by
a single family for thousands of years
however the Emperor could withdraw it at
any time in general planetary subjects
were more loyal to their household
leader rather than the Emperor himself
the Atreides in particular inspired
loyalty and Trust amongst their subjects
at the start of Doon House Atreides at
the request of the emperor abandons
Caledon where they had held fiefdom for
many generations though great houses
often plotted against each other this
was not usually done openly in varesh
atom the fourth conspired in secret
against House Atreides along with house
Harkonnen in the novel dune this was
done in order to avoid the combined
wrath of the other Great Houses of the
landsraad there is a philosophy behind
the far for Lucius system it suggests
that since humanity had spread out
across such vast distances a central
figure such as the Emperor was necessary
in order to provide guidance in the lies
the inhabitants of the Imperium the
Emperor would provide a certain degree
of focus to a chaotic galaxy this
central figure could be represented on
each planet by the leader of the Great
House which held planetary fiefdom the
Farah lucha system was flawed of course
as I mentioned in my house Harkonnen
video the harkonnens who were once
banished for their actions during the
Battle of Corinne were able to rise to
the status of a great house through
manipulation of the market Leto the
second saw through his prescient vision
that the father lucius system must end
it was necessary for his golden path he
knew that humanity would never survive
as long as it could be ruled by a single
interest he saw that a great scattering
was necessary to prevent humans from
stagnating and eventually going extinct
if a single individual could rule over
all of humanity then a single threat
could also destroy it after the
scattering following the death of the
worm God Emperor late to the second the
Great Houses did real father lucha
system was never reconstituted each
great house was a single entity amongst
a disjointed society consisting of many
groups vying for power it is noted in
the novel dune that the father lucius
class system was not rigidly guarded on
the planet Arrakis the desert dwelling
Freeman were not marked down on any
Imperial census no one knew exactly how
many of them actually existed the Fremen
in that sense lived outside of the
ordered security of the father Lucius
[Music]
you
[Music]